michael when the cameras were off we
just started discussing
the title of film courage and you were
gracious and complimented the name um
you refer to the word courage and you
talk about that in your
classes and the work that you do in
terms of i was saying i loved
the name of your company or the
enterprise calling to film courage
because at the core of
really the essential thing i talk about
is fear and courage
always with the character i believe
characters at the at the
core of everything when you're a
storyteller and what i'm
always interested in and what i always
want to encourage the writer to
look for is what is the fear
that is crippling in some way the
character at the beginning of the story
and how do they find the courage to
overcome that
i talk when i lecture about the terms i
use are identity in essence
because to me this isn't present in all
screenplays you could have a big action
script that doesn't involve a character
arc
but for most of the of the stories that
are layered
the character is suffering from some
moon
something happened in the past before
the movie began
that was so painful that they
believe they've dealt with it but
they've actually sort of suppressed it
they haven't blacked it out they know it
happened but they think that doesn't
bother me anymore so in shrek it was his
rejection
um or in in titanic
it was rose getting drummed in by her
mother the idea if you don't have a man
to take care of you you're not going to
survive
so though those wounding experiences
created this deep-seated fear and that
stuckness that i talked about at the
beginning
is just them living under that fear
and it's preventing them from really
doing what they need to do
to be fully to be fulfilled then as the
writer what you have to do is you have
to give
that character a goal you have to dangle
a carrot
in front of your hero that is so
enticing
either because it's such a big reward or
it's to prevent something horrible from
happening
that they are desperate to go after it
so that's the plot of your story is the
journey
as they go after that goal but the inner
is about them in pursuing that goal
realizing i'm
never going to get it unless i can find
this courage that i
don't have because i'm too afraid of
this
wound from the past of so they start in
this identity this false self
and they have to find a way to get to
their essence and who they truly are
as they gradually find this courage to
achieve the goal
and the rule is they can't get the goal
in the end of the movie
unless they found the courage and if
they do find the courage they've got to
get
they've got to win they've got to get
the girl or find the buried treasure or
stop the serial killer or whatever that
goal might be
so it's that intertwining of that outer
journey of the plot and the inner
journey
that the hero takes of transformation
that really interests me when i talk
about story and script